Five
Four
Three
Two
*electra glitch* https://www.youtube.com/user/pewdiepie
*100% Original Opening*
♪ I know ♪
♪ You see ♪
♪ Somehow the world will change for me ♪
♪ And be so wonderful ♪
♪ Live life ♪
♪ Breathe air ♪
♪ I know somehow, we gotta get there ♪
♪ and feel so wonderful ♪
♪ Its all for real ♪
♪ I'm telling you just how I feel so-
ƿ૯ωძɿ૯ƿɿ૯ : I'm sorry to interrupt this meme review 👏 👏 with a special Pew News news segment.
*pew news intro*
CNN recently reported there's been an outbreak of Ligma. So if you're at home right now you haven't heard about this
So if you're at home right now
You haven't heard about this
I highly recommend
You talk to your parents you study and read up on this to do whatever you can to protect yourself from ligma
I know this is mean review and I'm supposed to make memes or whatever
I know this is meme review and I'm supposed to make memes or whatever, but...
But I want to be responsible here. A lot of people have been trying to meme ligma like it's some sort of joke
But I want to be responsible here. A lot of people have been trying to meme Ligma like it's some sort of joke
I want to be responsible here.
A lot of people have been trying to meme ligma, like its some sort of joke.
*zooms in to something relevant*
Not funny. Okay, if there's one thing you need to know about ligma Felix what is like ligma
Not funny. Okay, if there's one thing you need to know about Ligma, "Felix what is Ligma?"
Not funny. Okay?
*ghostly echo: Not funny*
If there's one thing you need to know about ligma. Felix, what is ligma?
Number Ligma is not a joke
Number one:
Ligma. Is not. A. Joke.
*smb SFX*
Okay?
85% of humanity has died of Ligma
and I don't understand
how anyone can sink so low
make fun of people dying
Dying is like top five - one of the worst things
so, I don't-- I--
Why anyone would make fun of this ligma thing?
I don't get it
my friend Ethan Klein
passed away of ligma
Do you think this is some sort of joke?
Honestly, it's really upsetting I know I meme a lot on this channel
Honestly, it's really upsetting
I know I meme a lot on this channel
But there's also a time to be serious
serious finger: and that is now
let me tell you
okay, this might be shocking news to everyone
my favorite Fortnite streamer
Ninja has passed away of ligma
and I know what you're thinking
that sucks
WhO aM i GoNnA wAtCh PlAy FoRtNiTe NoW?
there's barely anyone playing that game
Ligma is a serious disease! And if it's not treated seriously, you could end up hurt.
*pew news crashes for a bit*
*no this is meme review >: (
PS: Take me to effing r/wooosh, I dare you. -CrSw*
*some dank remix*
Rule number two never ask what ligma is. That's what ninja did and that's what caused his demise ninja love Kali
Rule number 2wo:
Never ask what ligma is.
that's what ninja did.
And that's what caused his demise. :(
(Reads)
Ninja. Love Cali
W T F I thought you died from ligma.
WTF! I thought you died from ligma
What's ligma? Ladies and Gentlemen
what's ligma?
Speaker: Ladies and gentleman, we got him. (BE WARNED)
*EARRAPE*
*thanks Brad/Sive*
LIGMA BALLS BITCH
I don't even know if it's real or not
But just because of this joke everyone started spamming ninja.
Ligma
LIGMA Ha-ha-ha LIGMA
Ligma gotch you
So then, ninja had to start banning people.
Ninja : Let's start banning all the ligma stuff please.
>:(
Ninja : just like a start with like a 24-hour ban, and then just go straight to bans.
Why would you ban people from trying to spread awareness of ligma?
This is so sad. If this video gets 5,000 likes we could cure ligma right now
This is so sad.
If this video gets 5,000 likes we could cure ligma right now
I would never ban people from spreading awareness of ligma.
Doctor: Patty?
*door shuts loudly*
Doctor: Patty.
The test results came back
It's not good
You have ligma.
Patty: what's ligma?
Doctor (serious voice): Ligma balls
*senpai cries in silence*
*or laughs*
*not sure*
*He cringes. -CrSw*
Internet celebrities, left and right are hit by ligma.
I'm here to protect them
Okay. You might say, "Oh, this is pretty low of you Felix."
I'm trying to protect people so they don't end up like ninja.
Just look at ET
Young dir- actor. A young pop star with a bright future.
Look at him now.
*reads* Ninja: You can't defeat me.
Me: I know, but he can.
Ligma balls!
The life of successful people such as Ninja and Supreme Patty.
Ligma. *hit*
What are they afraid of?
Vampires = sunlight
Superman = Kryptonite
Internet celebrities
*let's not replicate what pewds is literally saying.
also, hit sfx*
Alexa, can we play Up Dog?
*RIP 399*
Alexa : What is up dog?
Pewds : Not much. What about you?
*RIP mic*
👏👏
The ligma meme gets a four
point
ｉｎｆｉｎｉｔｙ
This meme obviously, it's not gonna work anymore
But it worked on  the top streamer, Ninja.
and he got really salty about it, which makes it fun.
That's the only reason why it's funny
It's because he got upset about it
instead of uh
instead of *skratta* just meme-ing it.
*mob cheers for man to get up*
*man gets up and walks away*
*climbs a tree*
*becomes jesus*
We live in a time
where free thinkers
are truly
T r u l y thriving
Greek philosophers, excuse me, Go away.
All right, you will never be on the level of such as:
crying markiplier videos
Jordan B Peterson
*electric brain freeze*
*trying to harness memes*
Social justice warrior owned compilations
*electric zoop*
Owning libtards
*meme satellite connecting noise*
But the top of the top of the greatest freest thinkers of this planet, world, universe
etc
are Roblox commentors
you see Roblox has a censoring system where you can't comment
certain words
so they have to run an extra mile up here and
*neurons firing noise*
And they do it at ease. To express themselves in a savage way and the most savage way even possible
Delivering the sickest burn of all time such as
go commit die
oof
If you get hit by that I don't there's no that's worse than ligma.
If you get hit by that, I don't- there's no- that's worse than ligma
Definitely
or perhaps
go commit not alive
🔥🔥🔥
oof
*slurps some saliva*
ah
AH
I will swear word at you
I WILL SWEAR WORD AT YOU
*realises how intellectual people are*
oh yeah, well why don't you commit neck rope?
oow
ouu!
🔥ooo🔥
This gets me hyped. This gets me going
go commit
🔥🔥STOP LIVING🔥🔥
DAMN!!!
Damn, son. He got you good
He got you good Luigi, you, do, are,
gay, LOL
You do are gay LOL
gay lol.
AHHHH!
Son. Ah, son you got destroyed. You got-
po-
Pooped on! 💩
Do you are have stupid or something?
*moan*
AH
Man, those roblox commenters sure know how to get ya.
Stop being having autism
*contemplates life*
*Stares intensely at camera*
Hmm?
*where are the effects, Brad?*
or
the stronkest
of them all
*whispers* go commit not feeling so good
*brain nuked*
If you get hit by any of these comments at any points
There's only one thing and one thing only that you must do
you must commit sewer side
*music ends*
👏👏
Hopefully the YouTube bot doesn't
*skratta*
misunderstand what I'm saying. And I can finally, I finally figured out a way to express myself
Thanks to roblox commenters. Thank you. I thank you.
👏👏
You got a four
as well
Congratulations, Roblox. You've done well!
Congratulations roblox you've done. Well, there's not really that much of any memes
There's not really that much of any memes.
I think the ligma thing just really took over
But there is one meme if I truly have the power to kill memes, theres one meme
But there is one meme if I truly have the power to kill memes, there's one meme
I want to just die, okay? I never want to see it again!
It's this stupid black-and-white meme. It's this stupid meme. Ok, anytime. I see it
I wanna die
Stop posting these
What is this?
Wha-
I'm wearing the same shirt *laughs*
Phil, Don't do a lot of damage to that bucket, please stop!
Wow, the graphics in roblox look like they truly have increased!
Impressive
The only thing I appreciate about this meme is the minimalistic aesthetic of it
This is what a moron would read : XY XY XY XY XX. What does this mean?
Me and intellectual those X's is about to get it
Wait, isn't it- isn't XX the male? Oh wait. Oh male is XY?
an i d i o t
would say, "wow, they looks like he didn't finish his cereal"
me and intellectual: That white one is about to get, dammit
I can't even eat Oreos anymore. It's completely ruining it for me.
I can't watch my favorite Disney movie Tarzan anymore
It's completely ruined for me.
I can't even appreciate ancient Egypt hieroglyphic
Paintings
I can't even appreciate demonetization anymore. It's completely ruined for me.
I can't even-
*interrupted by sides swapping up*
Ok
Okay, this is epic
MINECRAFT!
DAMN!
DISNEY!
Kids watch Disney, Are you sick?!
DICES
Dices play kids. Are you okay?
POKEMON?!
Pokemon japanese 👏x2
What happened to me? *skrattar* It's so bad!
This meme gets a
!!! ZERO!!!
Just let it die! It kills all my favorite things.
Now, this is it for meme review. Hope you guys👏-
And this is a for meme review. 👏 Hope you got-
Felix 2: But Felix, you didn't review succome
Felix 1: What's a succome?
Felix 2: Succ on me balls, bitch!
suck on my balls
Felix 1: AHHHHH *collapses*
*cute music plays while you read the editor's message and Felix 2 smiles*
*pls save brad*
*I'll let you read that one. You're welcome. -CrSw*
*pewd hits away ad in 0.5 sec* Leave a like right now in this video,  subscribe, hit the bell button and I'll see you guys
Leave a like right now in this video subscribe hit the bell button and I'll see you guys
You've just been filled in and I'll see you guys in the next meme review
👏👏
*nostalgic smile for bros*
*Another nostalgic smile for bros*
*A.S.S. outro plays* to reach the 10 min. mark
tbh I, CrackerSwarm, had to do this subtitle thing twice because of yt being domb *still A.S.S*
and not making my work into the subtitles 😠 *hold on a bit*
also, the captions are made by some anonymous guy/girl/whatever their gender is *just wait a bit*
But other than that, thanks again for watching! 🙂 *or just leave already*
👏👏 meme review 👏👏
now here's their message, guys  *it's almost ower*
Bye guys <3 thanks for turning the captions on *why are you even here?
hope you have a great day today  *k bye :3*